Katy est juste une explosion continue de
grossir, de grossir, de grossir, c'est toujours à propos
du défi qu'est-ce que les gens disent qu'elle
ne peut pas faire c'est ce qu'elle fait ensuite chaque
chanson a quelque chose à voir avec sa vie
elle est sous une tonne de pression que le
monde entier regarde ouais non  si heureuse nouvelle
le divorce de Katy Perry ce qui s'est passé
là-bas vous n'avez pas à vous sentir comme si vous aviez
perdu de l'espace vous êtes original ne peut pas être
remplacé l'atmosphère dans laquelle j'ai grandi était
100% chrétienne j'ai commencé à chanter à l'
église je n'ai jamais vraiment eu d'autre plan
ce n'était pas un succès du jour au lendemain, elle a
signé sur un label, puis son label a
abandonné son peuple a dit qu'elle ne pouvait pas le
faire Je traversais
des moments sombres et déprimants mais c'est un voyage que j'ai
tellement appris de ce voyage que je pourrais être
comme un  une meilleure personne plus forte à cause de
cela,
vous devez vraiment être reconnaissant et savoir
que c'est un groupe de personnes différent
chaque nuit ces filles mon objectif
quand je joue des spectacles est juste de faire
sourire les gens
si vous avez un dre  dois-
tu partir en voyage pour réaliser
ce rêve